نشوف كثير في الأفلام شخص مثلًا
فاقد الذاكرة وضرب رأسه
رجعت الذاكرة مره ثانية
قصص مسلية
هذه الترجمة أُجريت خصيصًا لأصحاب الإعاقة السمعية (الصم).
اسمي جمعان الزهراني.
أنا استشاري جراحة مخ وأعصاب
تخصصي الدقيق، جراحات قاع الجمجمة
جراحات الغدة النخامية
والأوعية الدموية العصبية.
لا نحن بالعادة نرى أشخاص متوفيين دماغيًا
التشخيص عمومًا
الموت الدماغي ليس سهل
لكي أكتب في ملف المريض او أقرر أنه ميت دماغيًا
هذا الأمر يستدعي لوجود جراحين أو طبيبين في العناية المركزة
يقومون بعمل فحوصات معينة
بطريقه معينة في أوقات مختلفة
أو بنفس الوقت بحضورهم الاثنين
بحيث أن الفحوصات هذه نتائجها كاملة
تشير الى الوفاة الدماغية
أعتقد أن القصص التي نسمعها
ميت دماغيًا
أحد قالها
طبيب بالمستشفى أو بالعناية المركزة
بدون ما يجري الفحص لكن العلامات المبدئية
تشير إلى أنه ميت دماغيًا
حتى الموجودين حوله، يتداولون أن هذا المريض ميت دماغيًا
لأحد سمعوها بطريقة ما.
وبعد فترة رجع المريض
رجعت وظائفه العصبية وأكتشفوا أنه ليس ميت دماغيًا
هل مر علي شخص ميت دماغيًا ورجع عاش؟ لا.
مامر علي.
هو تشريحياً
الدماغ لا يختلف من شخص الى آخر
إلا إذا كان هناك طبعًا تشوهات
منذ الولادة، لكن لو أخذنا
شخصين طبيعين وسوينا تشريح للدماغ
التركيبة التشريحية لها
ماتختلف ابداً نفس التركيبة التشريحية
لكن الوظيفية ممكن تختلف.
لو أخذنا شخص موسيقي وغير موسيقي
وسوينا تشريح للدماغ
تشريحيًا هي نفسها، مجهريًا ممكن تختلف
يعني اذكر على سبيل المثال،
مريض كان مصاب بالتوحد في أيام التدريب
كان يلعب بـ
بمرسم
سقط فدخل المرسم في محجر العين
وسقط في قاع الجمجمة، مكان عميق جداً
قريب جداً من احد الشرايين المهمة بالدماغ
الشريان السباتي، المريض في الطوارئ..
كان مستيقظ
بيتكلم، لكن في ألم قليل
ما كان مأثر عليه كثير!
حركته طبيعية جداً، كان لازال
كان لازال في وعيه
فلما أُخذ للعمليات، كانت العملية خطيره جداً لأن المشكله
في الحوادث لما يكون في مثلاً سكين
أو أي شيء داخل في الرأس
نأخذ كل الاحتياطات
نعرف أن الشريان هذا ممكن يكون انجرح
وسحب الجسم الغريب هذا ممكن يؤدي الى نزيف
ممكن يموت على طاولة العمليات
فلما نسحبه نسحبه بطريقة
بحيث يكون المكان كله مفتوح
نشوف الشريان بالضبط وين؟
نقفل مكان النزيف هذا، ناخذ كل الاحتياطات
ولكن مع ذلك الفيصل
في العمليات هذه حظ وتوفيق الله.
الحاله التي فعلًا أثرت فيني كثير
هي حاله..
لبنت صغيرة
أنا شفتها في بداية دخولها المستشفى
جلست في المستشفى تقريبًا
ثلاث إلى أربع أشهر
مرت بمراحل كثير خلال الثلاث أربع أشهر هذه
كان عندها ورم معقد في قاع الجمجمة
أجريت لها ثلاث عمليات لاستئصال الورم
صارت معها مضاعفات في العملية وتوفاها الله.
نحن لأجل ذلك
يعني..
نحاول..
نسوي كل اللي نقدر عليه لأجل نصل
الى مستوى الخبرة
في تخصصنا، لأجل نساعد الناس
فكانت حالة البنت هذه
من أكثر الحالات التي فعلًا لامستني
وأثرت فيني.
في عندنا مصطلح طبي
في جراحة المخ والاعصاب اسمه الميكروسيفيل
هو كبر الرأس يصير الدماغ...
يصير كبير جداً والرأس كبير جداً، هذي بالعكس
تدل على اعتلالات في الدماغ
يعني مو شرط الشخص اللي كبير رأسه
يكون التفكير عنده أفضل.
"يعني ممكن يصير العكس؟"  أيه، ممكن طبعًا.
مافي عملية تجرى في الدماغ
إلا ويكون لها مضاعفات، الفرق فقط في نسبة
في نسبة حدوث المضاعفات هذه.
يختلف من مكان الى مكان ومن جراح إلى جراح
لأن كل مازادت خبرة الجراح
المفروض نسبة المضاعفات في العملية تقل.
ممكن الشخص يتكلم لغتين
يكون يتكلم لغة وحده وينسى اللغة الثانيه
او في لغة يتكلمها افضل من لغة
هذي تصير في بعض مشاكل أورام الدماغ
او بعد حتى بعض العمليات
ممكن تصير لمناطق معينه في الدماغ
أعتقد يعني في ناس
يقومون بعمل أبحاث على المواضيع هذه
إلى الآن لا نعلم بالضبط لماذا تحدث
نرى كثير في الأفلام يكون شخص مثلًا
فاقد الذاكرة وضرب رأسه ورجعت الذاكرة مره ثانية
ما أعرف أساس علمي لها،
كلها بالنسبة لي قصص
من أكثر الأشياء
اللي تؤثر علينا كجراحين
هي كمية الضغط النفسي
خلال إجراء العملية خصوصًا عملية الدماغ
بحكم تخصصي، عمليات حساسة جداً
الجراح يتعرض
إلى ضغط نفسي خلال العملية لا يستطيع أحد تخيله
لازم الواحد يعيشه
همي الوحيد خلال العملية
أن المريض هذا يستيقظ من العملية
مثل ما كان او أفضل.
في قرارات كثيرة نتخذها خلال إجراء العملية
هل نزيل الجزء هذا
ولا لا؟ ونسبة الخطورة لو أزلنا الجزء هذا
هل سأجرح الشريان هذا؟ او العصب الفلاني هذا؟
هل سيأثر على حركته في المنطقة هذه؟
هذي قرارات صغيرة،
تتخذ خلال العملية ...لكنها صعبة جداً
لكن مثل ما قلت اللي يجعل الإنسان يواصل
هو أن المريض يستيقظ بعد العملية و يشكرك.
يقولك "شكراً"
دعوة تأتي للطبيب على هاتفه
أو يمر على المرضى
فأمّ المريض تدعي له، أب المريض يدعي له، أخيه يدعي له
هو يدعي له  يدعي لأهله، يعني هذه
اللي يجعلنا نستطيع نواصل ونستمر.
بالرغم من كمية الضغط النفسي
الكبير جداً خلال الجراحة على الطبيب.